it's so nice to see that you're smiling
these are so much to celebrate the fact
that your birthday just passed a happy
belated birthday you turn the big
three-o I mean has it changed you as a
woman I feel so changed now I just feel
less like a human because I was like I
turned 30 I love you Michael but I want
other people I was inspired by you bees
you walked your cat
he took her cat for a walk and you had a
glass of wine what was happening that
day I know everybody's like I feel like
the cat I told Emmy Lou that's my cat's
name I was like you're famous now people
love you so I I was given Emmy Lou as a
Christmas gift five years ago for my
parents and when every little thing
happened I had to give her back to them
because I couldn't take off rode with me
and so she lives in Alabama now and my
mom told me she's a ragdoll cat so she's
very big and my mom said Emmy Lou loves
to take walks and I was like excuse me
what she was like Pete loves like and
I'm telling you every day at the same
time she would sit by the gate and kind
of like one out so you have her up and I
took a glass of wine out and I'm walking
this cat down the road and I was like
somebody has to video this this is the
most insane thing I've ever done in my
life so I just was like surely people
fool I think this is weird I just put it
on and it's become like a topic for
everyone
[Music]
you released a video while you've been
in isolation it won't always be like
this it's raw it's emotional how would
you describe the words behind this song
well it's interesting because I feel
like it continues to show me that it
takes on more meaning than I even
thought or me the ending of the video is
kind of how my world has changed you see
my band and I playing in our homes and
then I flash to actually all of the
footages from the last Canadian shows I
did with Old Dominion and how we had no
idea that that was about to be the last
time that we did that until who knows
what so it's been really cool to have
that song take on more meaning than I
ever thought
[Music]